hello and welcome to this video playing
silence silence see again did you
practice my benko repertoire a little
bit and see how things turn out okay
this is a possible i can go a 6am well
okay this is also not not a bad choice
weiter closed down the center or the
queenside I'm sorry the Queen side and
now we are dealing with a very closed
central formation I think that leg is
always find in those if I've blocked
positions okay took it this is this
feels very harmless to be honest he has
a weakness on deform and not much to
show for it d 5 is very hard to to make
yourself the only thing is that it still
super solid yeah i mean why this verse
yeah but it's not easy to break down
Jim maybe I don't know maybe I'm playing
this attack too quickly i mean i can't
play interesting more interesting stuff
like g5 for example it could be
interesting I don't need to play it in
such a technical way okay let's try this
it's an interesting idea
yeah it's it's a little bit on the risky
side but you have to do something and
maybe to punish White's passive play
here my idea is to kick the night away
and then go to deform
I thought you we are not sure really
this is not an easy position for wide so
now I can just take so it's one thing on
94 94 looks pretty good yeah that feels
like a good try to a tick or not think I
I will need to open the position anyway
here like g4 will essentially force them
to take what do you have something
whether it really looks downright
terrible but this is this is not bad i
mean i'll be able to recapture with the
porn thing is is it the best move I mean
taking with the bishop actually allows
me to play h4 soonish I know it have to
attempted to just install this this
structure here
I don't think that means anywhere this
is just speeding things up
yessum the queen is looking at g5 but
what is this actually doing yeah the
only idea would be to sacrifice on e4 in
this position so let's I have to watch
out for
maybe bring the bishop over here like
this and then be sure to see six if you
take that
I can also check on b3 here that would
be a check though
probably just just this
check so how is this going to be played
I go hook f3 look f3 you should do the
trick I always have a counter check
basically if it checks me only seven I
have look at seven check white resides
okay so it was a pretty nice pretty nice
one I think in general this kind of
structure is very okay for black the
queen side is completely blocked and I
don't see really where white chances are
in this position um here I i think i
should not take d-texas six is just a
strategic mistake because it gives me
the control over those squares and why
it has no active play here a key thing
is that this is 92 is so misplaced so
this was all pretty standard stuff night
h5 also was interesting this just
weakens the kingside i want to do this
anyway i'm not sure about this g5
business but i wanted to play aggressive
flame and see ya make make some pressure
here my g4 is already strong but h5 is
also strong you know the engine already
gives black like- 1.6 it is very very
awkward this thing would you eight now
but this cannot be bad King age 7 is now
given as the best move but this is
something that should win in the long
run it's an extra porn and it's not easy
to
it limits white skin and okay here i
actually mr. made castles was made okay
now i played this too quickly because i
was just I was anticipating the move and
I was thinking okay this is just not
working at all i just take everything
and okay this is this is of course
enough but age to wasn't made yeah i
think this was this was an all okay
check Andrew k3r threatening look at one
double check so and any check is outside
by a counter check doses always nice
also here on the ICC you have this they
have this check this check check check
check don't have that all that often
okay um I'm happy with the game against
salman here thanks for watching